hello everyone thank you for joining
we'll be starting with the session in 15
minutes from now at the scheduled time
that is 10 a.m cst and 8 30 p.m ist
and meanwhile we begin with today's
session
it would be nice if you could introduce
yourself in the chat box
so i can see some new faces today
hi
as well
i welcome those who have just joined uh
we'll be starting with the workshop in
more 10 minutes at the schedule time
thank you for joining
and meanwhile we begin with this session
it would be nice to hear from you
about your educational background on
your research background and what are
your research interests
hello everyone i would like to welcome
those who have just joined we'll be
starting with the session in five
minutes from now
thank you for joining
and uh thank you for introducing
yourself in the chat box some of the
participants who just joined
also meanwhile we began for the ones who
have just joined can introduce
themselves in the chat box tell us about
their educational
or research background
and what are their research interests
hello everyone i think we are good to
begin with today's session
so a very warm good morning good
afternoon or good evening in whichever
part of the world you are
[Music]
so today we are going to discuss about
the tools for genomic data analysis
to interrogate genomic variations for
cancer studies and to perform somatic
and germline variant detection
driver and passenger mutations copy
number variation as well as tumor sub
tonal deconglation
so before we begin with today's workshop
i would just take few minutes to
introduce ourselves
we are a us-based brandmatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy-to-use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
and over the past several years we have
had the privilege of working with a
number of organizations developing a
training program for research oriented
students faculty and democratizing
bioinformatics making this discipline
accessible to thousands of students and
faculty around the world
the research-based training programs are
a result of close collaboration between
pine powder and numerous academic
institutions that have participated in
content evaluation curriculum review and
project design
omixologic training has been completed
by over 15 000 participants from 162
countries and over 300 workshops and due
to this fast growth our team is working
with local and regional coordinators
that are helping refine the local
program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
so the training follows a project-based
learning approach using research-grade
tools to analyze data from top-tier
review journals we focus on six
different specialization tracks
which are oncology infectious diseases
precision medicine neuroscience data
science for biomedical data and
comprehensive training on omics data
analysis
i'm honored to introduce the founders
and the team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of the
tomball bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr lunet brotzky is the director of
troubled bioinformatics research center
and is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right
julia fanoff is an expert
bioinformatician avitovsky leads the
development of the tbi info platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple academic
publications
and he's developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omixologic training and
research fellowship
dr dragoventron is an accomplished
computational biologist with an
experience in large scale analysis of
multiomics data and data science methods
in precision oncology and protein dna
structural bioinformatics
and to introduce myself i am sunali
khari and i am the omixlogic community
manager i am responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a community managed by
find biotech
so now let's get up for today's workshop
but before we do so it's important that
you sign up on the omixlogic learn
portal
signing up will give you an access to
the omixlogic courses which includes
various resources on bioinformatics
precision medicine multiomics including
genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and epigenomics
data science that includes
bioinformatics using r and python
and also an access to the example
projects for different fields which you
could learn from and replicate your
research work
the users will be given directions to
access the tbi info platform as well for
processing and analysis of
transcriptomics data
the platform includes demo pipelines as
well as data management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections of this multi-omics
platform
so now let's quickly
take some minutes out of our
workshop schedule and sign up on the
book
so here is the link
to the portal in the chat box if you
have signed up
please let me know in the chat box by
putting in a one or yes tv
and those who are new today please click
on the link that i have put in the chat
box
go to the login button
and you can either create an account for
yourself
just simply put in your details and that
are required for creating an account or
sign up with any of your google accounts
i'll do so with one of my google
accounts
you can uh sign up along side so that
when dr raghav goes through these
resources that he wanted to share and
talk about in the workshop you can
follow these resources
and also take questions if you have any
while going through them
[Music]
thank you for the
responses now for those who have signed
up
already or have just signed up please
make sure that you have
an updated profile
now how do you go to your profile click
on the mail id here in the menu bar and
this will redirect you to your profile
section it's very important that you
have a complete profile
so that the community community knows
about you and also we can monitor your
progress
and
guide you how you can proceed further
you need to add a profile picture link
in your site
[Music]
thank you
so i was saying please add a profile
picture connect your social media
accounts and also add a prefab about
yourself that could include your
background and your research interests
again this information will help the
mentors to learn more about you
for every course work that you pick and
go through you will get some points here
and these points will take you from a
business level to an expert level
every workshop or program that you are a
part of you will be able to look at the
badges of the same over here and the
starter subscription means that you have
the access to the start content uh or
the start lessons of the courses
now i'll help you go through the
platform very quickly how you you can
navigate and go through these resources
on the portal so when you click on the
courses tab on the portal
uh you can find various resources listed
out here on the right side you can see
there are various tags so if you just
simply click on one of the tags let's
say i want to go through the courses
that
that are up there on the portal simply
click on the courses you will get you'll
get a list of them which includes
various resources are in python use for
bioinformatics and
various omix data types and so we have
the example projects as well
i'll be taking you through the portal
and also dr raghav will take you through
the lessons that he'll be discussing and
if you have any questions you are free
to ask us towards the end of the
workshop and also in between you can
either raise your hands or put a
question in the chat box and dr raghav
will be here to help you out with the
same
now let's begin with the workshop i'll
be passing on the stage to dr raghav
over to user
thank you very very much
yeah let me get my things in order
let me find ways to shut my screen
can you see my screen now please uh
confirm it
yes so we can
yes perfect thank you very much
okay
so
welcome everybody to today's symposium
or today's workshop where we are going
to discuss a lot about oncology and
speak about the challenges associated
with the big data in cancer research and
in this session we will also talk about
ngs data and what this data can reveal
about the biological processes and
clinical manifestation of cancer with
driver
driver mutations and passenger mutations
and how this tumor
develops and how it
how it
recruits cells from the tumor micro
environment and what we can actually
learn from the from analyzing the
mexican sequencing data and relating
that
to the phenotypical characteristics of
the tumor and different phenotypical
characteristics of the tumor so that we
can
learn a lot more about um cancer
genomics and cancer in particular so uh
to to go through some of the background
of cancer and
and the necessity to study cancer and
what are we studying and why are we
studying and different aspects of cancer
so we all know about
the importance of studying cancer it is
one of the leading causes of mortality
and morbidity worldwide and this the
cancer prevalence is greatest in the
western world and um
and the other world is also
unfortunately catching up and
approximately it's like 40 percentage of
men and women around the world will be
diagnosed with cancer at some point in
that during some point in their lifetime
and
it is estimated that around 17 000
children
will be diagnosed with cancer and will
and around 10 percent of them will die
of the disease so cancer risks uh risk
of developing cancer increases
dramatically with age with abnormal
weight with tobacco use and with
exposure to radiation and etc etc these
are one of the few uh driver
causes that that might actually increase
the risk of developing cancer so bottom
line is that cancer is a genetic disease
which is caused by cancer-causing
genetic changes and these changes can be
inherited genetic mutations or this
that is um that plays a major role in
about five to ten percentage of all the
cancer or these changes can be acquired
somatic mutations uh that are uh
developed or that that are acquired as
you grow of old age or as
more and more random mutations
accumulate in those genes that are very
sensitive to cause cancer
so as a result we can study cells and
and their progression from normal
healthy cells that found similar to any
other cells or cells in a tissue to
abnormal deregulated cell that form
tumors and and then they metastasize to
other parts of the body so um
and
understand their biology in particular
so this process takes time and and it
gives us a window of understanding how a
cancer develops from a very
very healthy cell to a very dangerous
disease so currently um opportunity and
the necessity necessity wise there is
there is an urgent need to identify new
and novel signature genes or biomarkers
for early detection and the better
progresses of cancer to improve their
quality of life of those who are
who have the high risk of developing
cancer so we will start today by
speaking about cancer biology at its
basic cellular and tissue level
and by discussing that we learn about
the role of dna changes and gene
expression variation related to cancer
risks and cancer progression and
outcomes so in order to conduct a
research on cancer one needs to know the
absolute fundamentals of these cancer
cells so we couldn't have we couldn't
start from even lower level than
understanding the role of variations
that is found in dna and
today's session is related to um
this
is
is
to introduce you to the concepts to the
uh
to the ways to understand uh molecular
factors in tumor development and to
understand uh comics data that can
unravel a lot of cancer biology and and
deep deepen our understanding in cancer
biology in general so
at its basic level cell division is
essential for all the cells and for all
for for our body to survive but the
division must be controlled just like
any other process there should be a
control mechanism for this so when a
cell divides it goes through several
cycles of regulated several cycles
of regulated
[Music]
controls that that use or that employ
special family of proteins that will
control the progression of cell through
the cell cycle by active by activating
uh different enzymes or group of enzymes
that are required for the process so
cancer cells are simply cells gone wrong
in other words they no longer
respond to the signals of
signals of those control
group of enzymes and hence cancer cells
originate within the tissue as they grow
and divide they diverge
further from normalcy and over time
these cells become increasingly
resistant to the controls and
control
resistant to the control mechanisms that
are successfully maintaining normal
tissues so in the end as a result these
cancer cells proliferate or divide more
rapidly than their and then their
progenitors which are the normal cells
and become less dependent on signals
from the other cells or signals from the
surrounding environment so uh
as the cancer cell progresses to be uh
to be a
uh to be a malignant uh cells or
malignant tumors they are even
programmed or they are even capable of
evading programmed cell death or
apoptosis and then uh develop multiple
abnormalities that will um
yeah that will characterize them as
different stages of cancers so at its at
its
last stage or at its group fourth stage
the cancer cells actually break through
the normal tissue boundaries and spread
to the new sites of the body uh by
metastasizing into the bloodstream or in
the
psych yeah into the
normal uh yeah um
lymph node or blood stream so to
remember different aspects of cancer
biology the hallmark features of cancers
were identified where these are
distinctive contemporary capabilities
that enable tumor growth and tumor
metastatic dissemination so these
hallmark qualities have evolved over the
past decades and now they stand at a
grand uh
11 different
homework character hallmark characters
so they
any tumor cells that are categorized as
tumor cannabis growth suppressors can
avoid immune destructions and etc etc by
they can promote tumor inflammation and
they can invade
normal cells and they can metastasize
and they can uh
promote genome instability and then
increase the number of degree of
mutation that is that then that one
normally associate with them and then
eventually they will resist cell death
and then they will also deregulate stop
derivating cellular metabolism and they
can for in the long run they can sustain
the proliferative signaling for for a
lot of uh time so these are the uh
recently identified hallmarks of cancer
which
in which they also mentioned there are
emerging hallmarks or emerging
characteristics that can or that might
become
principal characteristics of the cancer
later
depending upon the research that
progresses with them
so this
what is cancer cancer is a complex
condition that we already know so it
manifests
in changes to the cell regulation at
many levels not only at simple
deregulation of the cell regulations
level at many level so this results in a
problem as we observe as tumor a
malignant tumor develops across time as
shown in the diagram so simply a tumor
cell will consist of a tumor will
consist of cell
cells whose growth and morphological
characters are markedly similar from
those that of the normal cells and the
criteria for this malignancy
include increased cell proliferation
loss of differentiation infiltrative
growth to the nearest
near tissues and then eventually
to be able to metastasize to other
organs
so what happens to
what happens to cause a cell to become
cancerous at its basic level so a long
long time ago scientists could not offer
a coherent answer to this question they
knew that cancers basically arose from
cells that began to proliferate
uncontrollably within the body and they
knew that chemicals radiation and other
viruses even viruses could trigger this
change but exactly how it happened
they could not identify let's say
something like 25 or 35 years ago so
over the uh over the vast majority of
research done in the last 20 or 30 30
years or three decades um
our methods have and our research have
actually revolutionized
our understanding of cancer
and in large part this success was made
possible by a development and
application of novel techniques and
technologies molecular biology and
at the at the at the forefront of these
novel techniques they we ah we stand the
ability to understand the cancer through
um
through the detection and through the
understanding or through the analysis of
sequence variation by
sequencing the dna or dna code or
sequencing the
expression levels of the cancerous cells
uh
also so
the development in omix technology and
the
ability to record multiple uh omics data
see and
integrate them seamlessly to understand
uh cancer biology has completely opened
our eyes to new understanding of cancer
that we will discuss about
so uh the cancerous cells actually
differ physiologically from normal cells
in many way and these will allow them to
grow out of control as we saw so one
important difference is uh cancer cells
of cancer cells are less specialized
than normal cells that is um
normal cells will mature into a very
distinctive distinct cell types with
specific functions depending upon where
the cells appear in our body but
cancerous cells do not so over the time
uh over the time of its proliferation uh
unlike normal cells cancer cells
continue to divide without stopping and
they lose their specific specificity of
uh being in that organ
so uh
some of the morphological characters can
be summarized as cancer cells might have
very large and variably shaped nuclei
and they are composed of many dividing
cells in the disorganized arrangement of
cells of varying size and shape and they
they overall display a loss of normal
features that one associate with
different types and different varieties
of normal cells and normal ratios
so in addition one of the important uh
aspects or one of the important
characteristics or hallmark
characteristics of cancer cells uh to be
uh to be enable them to survive is they
are able to ignore the cells that ignore
the signals that normally tells the
cells to stop
dividing or to uh begin a process known
as programmed cell deter apoptosis so
which
apoptosis is absolutely necessary and
our body uses apoptosis to get rid of
unneeded cells and cells that have grown
grown really old so cancer cells cancer
cells may be able to influence the
normal cells molecules and other
reversals that surround and feed a tumor
in an area that is known as tumor micro
environment for instance a cancer cells
can induce a nearby normal cells to form
um
blood vessels that will supply the tumor
cells with oxygen and nutrients and
whatever they need to grow and these
blood vessels also remove waste products
from the tumor and eventually over time
the samples are
the the cells the normal tissue cells
that are
adjacent to the cancer cells will also
catch the signal will also get the
signal and become proliferative in
nature so um
another hallmark feature is they are
often
able to evade the immune system so
immune system in our body or specialized
cell cells we know that they protect us
from infection and other conditions so
one of the way that immune system will
normally protect us is by removing
damaged or abnormal cells from the body
but
cancerous cells are somehow able to hide
from the immune systems and evade their
immune attack
and hence uh survive for a longer time
even though they are morphologically and
completely similar dissimilar and
completely different from
the normal cells so there are two uh two
stages or two different types of
tumor cells
they are categorized depending upon how
they respond to the
immune cells or immune invasion some are
described as hot tumors hot tumors are
the ones there are the cancer cells that
show signs of inflammation meaning the
tumor has already been infiltrated by t
cells and the t cells are fighting to
reduce our
fighting to uh restore normalcy by
getting rid of the cancerous cells and
um and hence we have many and have large
a large amount of
inflammation in and around uh tumor
micro environment area so these hot
tumors are usually they are the ones
which will uh
which will respond to uh uh
respond to immunotherapy by using
checkpoint inhibitors so we can enable
immunotherapy by
enabling checkpoint inhibitors at
different time points of the tumor by
analyzing the tumor carefully and then
we can
turn the tumorous cells and we can
convert this gmat cells are divert the
tumor cells to programmed cell death but
we also have another kind of another
type of cancer cells which are
non-immunogenic and they are cold tumors
and they have not yet been infiltrated
by t cells and this is a sign that
immune response will not work for cold
tumors for some reasons which are not
yet very clear so these types of tumors
are usually treated with traditional
cancer therapies like uh
like
chemotherapy radiation therapy etc etc
so most breast cancer ovarian cancers
prostate cancer pancreatic cancer and
glioblastomas are typical
cold tumors so that's why they are one
of the top cancers to be cancers of
interest and people are really
trying to understand their basis of how
they develop this
ability to hide themselves from immune
related attacks and we spoke about hot
cancers and the some of them
some of the cancers
some of the tumors which are hot cancers
and they
respond to the immune therapy are
blood cancers or tumors that occur
occur in skin skin cells or melanoma or
bladder or kidney
carcinoma and
nss nsclc or non-small cell lung cancer
so they they are often they often
respond to
different
immunotherapies by differing in their
efficacy levels and
by understanding their response levels
it will be
yeah
a treatment strategy is actually devised
to counter their proliferation
so
the main reason a cancer is so serious
uh is its ability to spread to the body
because unlike other uh altered disease
state um
cancer cells can actually at its last
stage or at this fourth stage it can
spread locally by moving into the
circulation circulatory system
first by um
[Music]
first by spreading regionally to the
nearby lymph nodes and then it can
spread to distance distant parts of the
body using their blood vessels so these
when this happens it is called
metastatic cancer and for many types of
cancer it is also called stage four
cancer so
metastasis is a process in which these
cancer cells
spread to the other parts of the body so
some of the hallmark features of these
metastatic cancer is when observed under
microscope are treated tested in many
different ways metastatic cancer will
have features like that of the primary
cancer are not like the cells
are not like the tissues in which these
metastatic cancers uh arrive but or
metastasize that for example um
for example breast cancers that spread
to the lung is is called as or is is
often is metastatic breast cancer and
not lung cancer so they are treated
similarly to how
how
breast cancer at its original location
is being treated
and that's how
cancers divide
so
i will stop here to ask if you have any
questions or if not then we will proceed
further
[Music]
so so far we have been introduced to
different biological aspects or
different biology of the cancerous cells
that
and and trying to inquire uh
what makes these cancer cells uh so very
different so and what makes this cancer
cell so
serious and uh
what is the absolute necessary to
understand the different aspects of
biological aspects of
cancer so we saw about different
hallmark features of cancer and one of
the ways in which we can understand how
these characteristics are different
characteristics characteristics of
cancer relate to
cancer how does telomerase function in
cancerous cells uh thus via i don't know
the specificity of telomerase's function
in cancerous cell
so
we might have to refer to the existing
publications or for that when we have
time maybe we can do that later or yeah
um
right now i do not have expertise in in
the telomerases function in cancer cells
so let's move forward in how many
different ways we can probe or we can
understand the variations in these
cancer cells and relate that to the
phenotypical characters or these
hallmarks that make the cancer cells
cancer cells
so we will we will now speak about basic
translational and oncological research
in which we are going to uh we are going
to
discuss about dna the genes and the and
the differences on variant variations in
the genes and how these elements are
studied using next generation sequencing
techniques and how they have evolved to
ah
evolved to help or assist cancer assist
our understanding in cancer biology as
such so
the the ability to understand different
data that that arises from
i have another question here are there
any specific changes in the cell cycle
that are more predominant in mutations
that elicit cancers information yes of
course there are because as i mentioned
and there are regulatory
elements and regulatory
processes that will stop or that will
program the cell to program cell death
that will stop the cell cells from
proliferating
uncontrollably and cancer cells are
somehow
they have found a way to evade these
responses
yes there are studies in how cancer
cells metastasize and
you can refer to something that that is
recently i mean
developing the last two or three years
or even five years it's called ct dna or
circular circular trans um transposing
dna something like that so where
metastasizing cancer cells will actually
eject or will actually uh leave out or
will actually
yeah
circular dna will escape from the meta
metastasized cancer cells and this will
often um
increase the tendency to metastasize in
further different places ah escaping the
administrative message for one body to
enter the blessing yes but cancer cells
is not a foreign body i mean it it
eventually started it starts as a normal
normal cells and then they have somehow
found a way to evade the
immune responses to
to proliferate so let's move ahead so in
order to understand
how
how for example the dna variation data
and how different omics data will help
us
will help us study or will help us
understand the
major features or major characters
characteristics of cancer cells or
cancer biology we we have
we have to get some introduction or some
some introduction to different omics
data that are available like phenomena
genomics epigenomics transcriptomics all
of these data can be generated using
next-gen sequencing method and what is
also known as high-throughput sequencing
methods the data can show detailed or
these data can show detailed information
basically about the genomic variants
about the patterns of gene and iso form
expression and about the patterns of
different uh epigenetic modifications
that we can relate to the phenotypical
hallmarks or characteristics in this
case and the tumor cells
characteristics so
about the basics and translational
research in oncology we have
we have
different ways in which cancer is
studied and basic research in cancer is
performed one of the ways is using
a very viable and very
usable model systems like
patient-derived cell lines where the
cancerous cells from the tissues from
the patients are actually grown in the
petri dishes and then they are studied
for multiple parallel
studies that will help help them or help
us understand the different hallmarks of
these tumor cells are too much issues
and in
a more
in a more um
accurate way one can graft these tumor
cells into immunocompromised mouse and
grow the tumor cells inside the mouse
which are known as
patient-derived genograph models and the
and then these mouse can be administered
different
different mouse and the petri dishes
cell lines can also be administered at
different
therapeutic agents or treatment
strategies and their response to these
different treatments can be studied and
whatever treatment that seems to work
for the
for the basic tumor cells then that
treatment will be
tried and tested to those patients who
are
whose tumor cells seems to respond to
the treatment strategy this this is a
way um this this method is called
targeted cancer therapy or
personalized treatment or precision
oncology which will help us basically to
isolate or to
stratify the treatment strategies and
treatment
treatment
options for different people who respond
completely differently to
cancerous treatments so
so we know that yeah we we spoke about
the availability of the omics data and
the promise of the omics data in in
understanding cancer biology so since
the since the beginning or since since
the uh
first sequencing of human genome project
in 2003 there has been a steady growth
in the high throughput sequencing of
multiple genomes and that they also
include cancer genomes and
transcriptomes and that has produced a
large amount of big data so this brings
itself a typical big data problem where
we have large amount of unstructured
data and very
few or very uh
remarkably lower amount of
structured data and analysis method that
are capable of analyzing these big data
that are being deposited uh
yeah the deposit which is being growing
exponentially so different omics data
many of the such data types and
different comics data types are
generated at a very high speed and
require complex computation data
processing and
these different omics data types will
obviously need different pipelines and
different analysis methods to be
to be set up to understand and to uh
identify
understand their um
understand their uh
characteristics and relate uh the
variations that one uh usually observes
and usually tries to uh usually
identifies with a mixed data and relate
that to the phenotypical character of
the tumor of cells or cancer cells in
this context but this can usually be
done for any uh any sample in an altered
state of of their physiological
condition so the
the basic um
uh
the basic way in which uh this is being
done is uh is uh when the biological
samples are subjected to the next genera
generation sequencing method the
sequencing method actually collects all
the dna from the samples and shares it
into million pieces and these million
pieces are then
amplified using a process called bridge
amplification method uh inside of flow
cell and after this amplification these
flow cells are then introduced into the
next generation sequencing machines and
these machines are will then convert or
will then use user combination of
image capture technology to convert
these biological samples into
letters of nucleotides that will read
that will read the nucleotide sequences
one by one so these digital data that is
produced as a result of next generation
sequencing method which handles the
biological data are unstructured and
they are
basically
different reads of
dna sequences called that differ called
from different uh
fragment of the uh fragment of these
shear dna so in order to build or in
order to identify where these different
pieces will match or will map onto the
whole
genome sequence we have to take or we
have to consider a reference sequence in
this case a reference sequence of human
genome and then we we use a method
called mapping which is essentially
multiple sequence alignment procedure
and we take these fragments of dna
in the short reads and then place it on
to their respective place in the whole
genome sequencing method so when we do
that this is this is what we get
typically all those small
horizontal
red pink and blue dots blue bars are
actually reads that are placed in
different position in the whole genome
sequence
reference genome sequence which are
which is essentially at the
top as a frame of reference so by
placing these we will be able to
categorize or we will be able to
understand
the variations of these uh
variations that these reads or
or of these sequenced data possess in
comparison to the reference genome and
these variations are the one
like like the one that we observe here
are the one which categorizes or which
authorizes our sample so by
understanding or by tabulating by
eventually
[Music]
i identifying different numbers of these
variants
we use a procedure called variant
calling algorithms and by doing that we
will
be able to list out and categorize and
annotate these different variants for
their involvement in uh cell
proliferation or involvement in
different
different pathways that are related to
cancer biology or different cell
proliferation
pathways or different immune
immunities pathways and basically we
were trying to
take these significantly observed
variants that
those are the differences compared to
the reference genome and try to connect
them to the different hallmarks
characteristics of the cancerous cells
or tumor cells that are that is under
consideration or that is under study
so
um
the main axes are the main
main
sub plots which which are the result of
this advanced or which are the result of
this advanced genomics analysis is the
ability to
handle single nucleotide variants and to
analyze the mutability data or mutation
data and to perform differential
mutation analysis and to detect copy
number variation in different biological
ah samples and biological data so we
will actually today perform some of the
some of the demo pipelines and
another pipelines and we will map we
will visualize and we will detect
significant changes in the dna sequences
by comparing it to the reference genome
and
by also pairing it with the different
physiological aspects of the
phenotype of the samples so at its basic
at its characteristics level of this
mapping or of these uh sequencing
characteristics we have to go through
some of the way in which these sequences
can be characterized and in one of the
way in which these sequences can be
characterized is using
or
by by calculating depth and coverage of
the sequences so
simply sequencing depth is the total
number of aligned reads from the
sequencing machine and
they are yeah they are usually in the
units of number of reads that are
aligned to the
reference genome and um those they
become the sequencing depth and
sequencing coverage in next-gen
sequencing terminologies actually
describes the relationships or relation
between
sequencing reads under and the reference
genome for example
a whole egg whole genome or whole exome
or a locus in which we are interested in
for example
if i am going to take all of the
reference genome then it's simply the
number of the sequence basis or number
of bases covered by ah by these reads uh
divided by the uh total number of bases
that is present in one half point uh
reference genome and if we are going to
target only at specific area by uh
sequencing uh by targeted sequencing
method or by targeted sequencing
approach then
the number of
bases in the reference will get
converted into number of bases in the
reference area because since we are
targeting only those area so these will
become very important in the case
of um
detecting variations that are not
that are not
very common or very uncommon
to learn more about this let's take a
look at a specific example where
by going through this example we can
arrive at at an optimal coverage for
tumor dna sequencing to be so when we
want to identify or
what happens and what should we do if we
want to identify very rare variants in
in tumor
samples so
we know that tumors can be very
heterogeneous which means that the
cancer cells has its own i mean which
means that different parts of the cancer
cells in the same tumor will have its
own characteristics genomic features and
and they are of high variability in
nature because ah
different regions of these tumors will
not have the same or similar
genomic variations when they are
compared with each other so
for example if there is if there is a
variant or
if there is a variant in 10 percentage
of the cells and if the um
if the heterozygous variant are found or
the variants that are found in only one
copy of the deployed genome is 10
percent of the cells and the tumor is
deployed and then this variant will only
be identifiable in five percentage of
the reads of our reads at its best so in
order to uh increase our ability to
detect these a lower amount of a lower
percentage of
variance we should have to or we will
design experiments where we determine
the number of reads
that should carry a variant or that
should carry this significant variant
and and consider it as
valid
statistical
differences so it is often a common
practice to start or to put a threshold
of
50 reads per um
50 reads as a coverage or as a depth for
clinical applications to be
sure that um the variant that we are
observing is real and it is not an
artifact of uh
of the
sequencing error or technical error
which will also be found uh often so
considering this threshold we would need
something like 1000 reads in in any
particular position to identify a
variant present at five percentage level
because we want to identify or we want
to statistically make that five
percentage variant to be significantly
if we have to do it then we have to have
1000 leads
for any particular position so this is
one of the reason um
this limitation or this number of
expectation of high very high reads for
uh for uh to enable us to identify a
significantly
rarer variant is one of the reasons why
targeted sequencing and or
sequencing which are aimed at uh which
are aimed at a specific loci the rather
than the whole exomark whole genome is
mostly used in um in in understanding uh
tumor diagnosis or tumor prognosis
methods and human biology so
so this is how it uh it actually works
because um
when we have when we have a better
subclonal population or when we
sample our data sample our tissues from
cells that that resemble morphologically
resemble each other which might not be
which might not which might not which
might still have inherently possess some
heterogeneity but at least we can have
some sort of
choice from which the samples are
collected then we can
also improve our ability to detect
a specific uh
significant variant so we have been
talking about this variant and we have
been talking about the variant calling
pipeline that we we can set up using
turbo bio info platform and
how are these reported and how are the
uh uh what is the output of such um
variant calling pipeline so the variant
call calling pipeline actually reports
our variance in a in a file or in a file
format that is called vcf file format we
have not discussed about the other file
formats but we will discuss about
variant calling file format because um
we are focused more on the mutation of
of the cancerous genomes and how they
relate to uh
relate to the
hallmarks of the cancer cells so a vcf
file will basically
or at its simplest level should have uh
this tabulated information which tells
at what position this variation occurs
and what are the quality scores of the
sequencing quality scores that are
associated with the variant calling
associated with this variant calling and
etc and we have uh different
explanations of what these uh um
what these headers mean so there are
specific algorithms which can read these
variant calling files and
and subject that to
further analysis we can visualize the
variant calling
vcf file and then
identify where these and where these
mutations fall in the
in the context of uh whole you know in
the context of our reference for zero so
before moving on further let me stop
here and ask if you have any questions
and if you do not have any questions i
will also share my screen for setting up
a pipeline which we can visualize now
okay
so please please share your questions in
the chat window i'm following the
chat window uh
uh
okay are there any studies and how much
okay with this we uh describe discussed
okay let me share my screen and
i hope you all should have your uh
demo account for the
turbo bioinfo platform if you have then
you can actually follow it along follow
along with me or if you do not have then
you can follow along with me when you
have the um
[Music]
yeah when you have your account ready
after the yeah with the reference uh
with the uh recording
let's
is my screen visible now
it's not visible
yeah now it's loading for me okay it is
visible okay perfect thank you very much
so
so in the server
that that is a separate section for
cancer biology and this section will
have a lot of
associated algorithms than one one
usually ah performs using genomic data
analysis today i am going to show you uh
some of the demo pipelines that one can
access from the genomics data analysis
for um
for cancer studies but eventually we are
going to populate this or we are going
to include lot of a lot more you know
demo pipelines in cancer biology section
also so if you click and open this
cancer biology section we have a
large range of um
a large range of analysis methods and
analysis programs that are capable of
accessing that are capable of addressing
uh
multiple different comparisons and
multiple different procedures too
for
that can be performed on an extensive
sequencing data of cancer cells uh
in comparison with the normal cells or
encompassing the adjacent power so for
for this purpose for our purposes let's
go to
uh where we can access the demo pipeline
from and
in the under the genomic section is
where we can access the demo pipeline
under the mutation variant and parallel
analysis of mutation variant data is
where we can access the
variant calling cell lines demo pipeline
so once
we click this this is what you will get
from a demo pipeline if you don't know
what a typical demo pipeline is
we have uploaded the data and we have
performed the analysis and
and
and presented
and we have
given you
access to these demo pipelines so that
you can experience uh
you can have the experience of setting
up analysis pipeline for uh for the data
for various different data so for each
type of analysis we have a different
demo pipeline associated and they are
found under those ah drop down boxes
from each and each different each and
every different section
so since we have uploaded the data you
do not have to go through the process of
uploading uh heavy a heavy load of data
and
we usually start the demo pipeline with
the start so the demo pipeline and also
the also the pipeline in general are
color coded in such a way that um
your next option will light up so my
only option now that lights up is start
so i start and it tells you what this
specific uh option does to your data by
also giving you uh
an
option to going through our option to
set different parameters whenever you
have those parameters associated with
that so um
this will tell you what a typical
pipeline is and what what can we do with
this uh variant calling pipeline
so i start and suddenly after my
starting i have two different options
that light up and depending upon where i
want to go the pipeline will change its
output
as as we are setting up two different
completely two different routes and two
different types let's now uh perform
mapping of our reads to the um
to the to the sequence or to the
reference genome so i do a mapping
using bow tie two and this tells you
what this algorithm actually does and we
and we also give a reference for
reference from which we can
access the original algorithm and
if you say ok then i have only one
option that is lighting up which is to
visualize our map reads that are mapped
onto the
mapped onto the whole genome reference
sequence so this will tell you how or
what we can do with the visualization
and
it tells that jbrowser
a genome browser
is is what is used to visualize this
mapping output of the about i2 algorithm
and i say ok and i see that the end
option is highlighted and i that is the
only option that i highlighted so i end
this
option
to finish up my pipeline so at the demo
pipeline this is how you will finish and
after finishing it up you will get
access to all the output files that you
will get
when you typically run this pipeline so
when you typically run this pipeline
this is the output files that you will
get this is this will be very helpful
for you to
download these output files and perform
some of the other analysis so that you
can understand how to
how to
relate and how to
analyze identify and visualize and
annotate the different variants but this
is not a variant calling a pipeline this
is a visualization pipeline as seen here
only mapping under mapping section and
then we have done on the visualization
and visualization section and here in
this specific area we have a link to
visualize our mapping so i click this
the jbrowser
tool opens up in another window so i
wait for this to load and by loading it
actually loads the alignment file and
we will wait for this to load so uh a
typical typically how would you how you
would navigate a jbrowser output it's
it's like
clicking different tracks so each one of
these are called the track so now i see
it's getting loaded so uh
this is a track that that is reference
sequence track and that is
enabled here if i
unclick this that track will disappear
and if i click this that track will
appear but this is now appearing here i
can also
unclick this and then click these two
later but if i do that it will take long
time to load so what do we see here so
at its basic level we see the reads that
are aligned to different position in our
genome uh reference genome now we cannot
see the reference genome because it says
zoom into c sequences we can zoom in
much further
and then let's see if we can enable okay
now i can see some colors
and now i can see some sequences so
typically you will have the forward
reads at the top and the reverse rate at
the bottom and you'll have three
different uh orf
three different translation of
these reads or these um not reads uh
forward strand and reverse strand and
three different translation of these
genome sequences in dominance sequences
are given if you are not interested in
that then you can turn it off we don't
want to show translation we want we want
only this and then um
and then we see how the mapping
procedure is so it this
this coverage actually gives you the
coverage of coverage at
the position the height of the bar is
actually the coverage at different post
position and this is the read that is
mapped on to this specific uh
um
genome let's load up a couple of more
reads uh
i think i should not select everything
let's let's do that
yeah so i have the reference genome and
then load up all the
reads first i load the
coverage and then i load that specific
read and i load another coverage
then i load that raid so let this load
and then when we scan through this or
when we go to important areas where we
want to identify or where we want to
locate our
coverage and
alignment of our files we can see that
let it load it's still loading
yeah now i see some more coverage
let it finish loading
yeah so here here you see there is a
there are some different colors that are
associated here though those are the
variants that are observed in our
sequences with reference to the uh
with reference to the reference genome
sequences once the coverage loads we
will see a marker here which tells that
we have a statistically significant
variant associated with our mapping onto
the sequence here with our rate sequence
here so we are waiting for that to load
and
after it loads then we can
click
that
specific variant and understand what
that is
what that
variant is
so this variant is observed only in one
of the sample and this is not observed
in the other sample so this by this we
can understand uh
how
i mean by by this we can understand
how sample one is different or group one
is different from group two and we can
relate that to the phenotypical
characteristics so this is just a random
position that i picked and you can pick
up some interesting positions like
tp53 g and you have the ability to go to
g in this
one by selecting the specific
gene name and then when we see when we
go to that gene
i don't think it went there
yeah then we have a lot more coverage i
can you can see that it's
covered a lot because yeah um
and
too much data to show zoom in to see
detail so let's zoom in a little bit
more
so you have all those
variants here
tp53 gene and the genes annotation is
given here
because we have actually clicked on
genome gene so this is the
gene annotation genome genes annotation
which tells different iso forms of the
tp53 gene so now we are targeting only
the tp-50 kgs here we can see the exo
electrons and introns we will also look
at those extension translator um i want
to see if this s p loads or not
okay we will let this load and i will
take some questions if you have um
yeah
okay
do you have any other questions any more
questions please
this is the time to ask until this one
loads
how do i view the output files on
jbrowser you can download jbrowser and
then use the bam files or some bam files
to load it up uh a bam file
alignment output file that is the one
that you have to load in jbrowser but
you don't have to load in the plugin
that we have created for you
because this will take
this will
naturally load the bam files here you
can see that dot bam files are the one
that you load you can also load up the
um variant calling file which we are
going to see in the next section i hope
if it
loads
if it floats a little bit quickly then
we will be able to see but but
anyway the the main aim for this
demonstration is you can visualize these
reads and let's see if we can zoom in to
see
variance
excuse me
sorry yeah
so
whatever output we're gonna visualize
here is it will it be the same if we do
this uh do it in ucsc browser
yes
okay yeah
it's going to be the same the
visualization is going to be same but
you will have different features
obviously but uh so the visualization is
going to be the same
so yeah this will give you the location
of the mutation but it's taking long
time to load so let's uh stop here and
we will let it load and we'll go back to
the presentation we might will come back
because we have some more demonstration
for uh to show
so where is my
yeah
so what i wanted what i actually wanted
to
demonstrate you is
by visually scanning through different
regions or different interesting regions
of
of the genome one can obviously visually
verify and
identify a different
different mutated variants the using the
mapping pipeline but we don't have to
resort to uh this mapping pipeline to do
uh this ma
yeah um pipeline that maps the reads
onto the genome to perform this manually
we can use variant calling pipeline and
and perform these analysis that will
give you a list of mutations or list of
variants that are identified in a
vcf file so those vcf file can also one
load up uh in the jj browser or
similar software similar visualization
software and um we can quickly relate to
possible mutations which we will do it
in future so before doing that so um
this is the associated uh publication
whose
whose data that we will take so the data
that we just discussed is is simply
some cell lines data
the aim of that pipeline is is to uh
demonstrate you how to visualize bam
files using jbrowser so that's that's
what you see you can
you can visualize the
bam files using
jbrowser it's still not loaded that's
really crazy okay
so uh you will get a mark i will i'll
show you when it finishes loading
so
in this paper actually what they studied
is they they uh targeted a
few sites like tp53 and few
cancer-related genes and they target
sequenced these uh
these genes and uh
and then they i for uh for two
conditions for uh unemployed for
unemployed uh patients and for deployed
um
patients uh
also so they found out that um the
cancer patients who had aneuploidy
suffered more uh are um they are
observed to uh contain more uh mutations
in the tumor-related pathway genes and
then like tp53 and myc amplification
they are higher for underpriority case
with the
with the um
with the cancer and for uh in contrast
uh for the amount of uh
years that they followed uh the deployed
um
uh the the the diploid
people uh people who are suffering from
cancer one they did not die of cancer
and two they showed a lower frequency or
lower rate of mutations in these
key
mutation
sites so we took this sample and these
samples and then we ran a
variant calling pipeline using free bias
software so this
variant calling pipeline is just one
natural extension of the pipeline that
we ran for
that we ran for our mapping
analysis so after mapping a process we
just run a free bias algorithm which
will take
these mapped on read mapped file or dot
bam file alignment mapping file and then
it produces a statistically significant
variant in a
pcf file folder so you can obviously
visualize those two which i'm going to
show you how to do that
so if you um
whereas
this is not the case yes
so in this typical pipeline this
pipeline is is like
a simple extension of uh
yeah i hope you can see my screen a
simple extension of a mapping pipeline
where we
we perform visualization and then we use
free bias to
call for the variance and then we finish
the pipeline so this also gives you all
access to the vcf file that it actually
gives you
that it actually produces and we can
visualize this luckily this
visualization i have actually loaded and
hope that that still stays and this is
what you will see in a visualize in the
visualization of pcf files
for this specific pipeline so in
addition to the bam files that one can
load you can also
load um
you can also load
the vcf file or the vcf file format that
that is an output of the free bias
software so this is the output of the
freebie software the vcf file that one
can look up for example you have all
sorts of uh
variant that are tabulated in that to
cover this specific area or this
specific genome position and we can zoom
out to
understand more about what this position
is
this seems to load a little bit quicker
than the other one
so
as i mentioned earlier so this specific
study
actually performs analysis on
tumor-related genes and the and collects
or
takes or analyzes their mutability or
not mutability analyzes their frequency
of mutation so what gene is this this
gene is tp53 how do i know because i put
it one i put it or we can search for
tp53 and go there like
pp 53 uh
and you will get it all different iso
forms and everything of tp53 is here
and
and these are the mutations so these are
all the uh variants that is that one
associate with this specific tp53 so you
can click on one of these mutation and
we will have you'll have their feature
details uh detail here where you see
what mutation is this this is a
smv or a single nucleotide variant that
uh mutates uh adenine to thalamine at
what position and at what length etc etc
all the other associated uh files so we
can see it so um
yeah i think show sample filters yeah
i think this tells out of
how much of these samples they have
this specific mutation but
uh how much time will this session take
i'm hoping to finish by another 10
minutes
let's see
so this is for the uh
for the uh what sample uh this is for
the anaploid samples so one observes a
lot of mutation as one sees the
unemployed samples i wanted to tell you
that and if you see the same for the
deployed samples or
one can see
the reduced amount of mutations in the
deployed samples in this specific area
or many different areas but one of the
areas where you can see a major
difference is this ah seven
seven six seven two hundred or some six
seven one hundred in this area where you
don't see a lot of mutation uh generally
peaking out but if we go to the same
location
um
in this
seven six seven seven seven six seven
six two hundred one hundred to two
hundred uh let's see seven six seven six
yeah this is these are the exons that i
was talking about um
so yeah in 100 to 200 you obviously see
a lot of different
mutations
yeah you see that there are
significantly a larger number of
mutations in these areas when you
compare to
deployed
samples so this is these are all one of
the ways in which you can
you can actually perform
these variant calling pipeline analysis
and then visualize that and obviously
you can
load up these alignment tracks
and that will show up visualization that
just like the one that we visualized
earlier
um
like this where is that visualization
like this uh visualization and then they
show which are of
what samples and which which ones of our
samples will actually uh contain uh
specifically contains these mutations or
not that one can identify so by
significantly uh
by identifying specific mutations and
then one also has the ability or one
also has a tools to uh enable us
annotation um
variants that are that are observed in
um databases like clinvar or cosmic that
can help us in annotating the variance
that one usually sees uh that one
usually observes in our uh data
yeah so
so this is this is how uh you can
perform a variant calling uh
analysis and uh um pipeline and
understand the difference in variant
calling so obviously you don't have to
perform these two separately uh if you
follow uh
more tutorials and if you follow the
genomics course in the
um
in our talk about you know in our
learnomics portal then you will have
methods to perform
differential mutation analysis which
will actually understand which will
actually help you
locate those mutations or get a list of
those mutations that are observed
differentially in in one set of samples
with respect to the other set of samples
for example in this case with the
unemployed versus deployed samples are
um in this case uh tumor samples versus
adjacent normal samples these are the
contrast that we can set up when
when you can find data for this
you can find data for these uh analysis
so what are the filters should be said
to make sure that the resultant variants
are true variance
um
they are actually they are actually done
the filter filters are actually set by
the algorithms and they are going to
display or they are going to report only
those variants which are called and you
can if you want further filtering you
can use the quality scores that are
associated with each and every
call
to narrow down your different multiple
different variants that are called by
these algorithms most of these
algorithms will actually call these
variants quite liberally or quite
what is a
not very aggressively quite leniently so
you can perform an additional layer of
threshold setting like using quality
scores to
identify or to
limit your variance to specific set of
specific levels so that
you have higher confidence in uh in
these variants that are called from
these different um
algorithms so uh let's let me stop share
for this particular pipeline and let's
go back to the um
go back to uh
questions if you have any uh and also
quickly break through uh what do we have
next in the
um
in our presentation
so yeah this is how we can do but uh um
a lot more detail on how this is done
and and and the demo sessions and other
information can be had can be had in for
upcoming programs in our uh uh
in our schedule and also in in the
upcoming symposium in uh
that is uh that is taking place in uh
next uh next week so i think at the end
sonalika will brief you
about the symposium and we will quickly
break through another important
variation that one has to keep in mind
while performing uh specifically while
trying to understand tumor biology or
trying to relate the
significant variations to tumor biology
this is this is called copy number
variation so copy number variation can
actually arise due to different
procedures like duplication deletion
insertion and translocation and
these can results in this can result in
multiple copies of the same gene
occurring in in the genome and that will
have significant effect in the uh
in our uh
tissue conditions and tissue status so
i'm not going into higher detail here
let's breeze through for example this is
one of the
example where this structural variation
as it is generic genetically called or
generally called
this is one of the example where the
copy number variation will actually
result in
result in different phenotypes and and
it is going to
cause uh harmful genetic phenotypes when
they completely differ from the
normal samples or when they completely
differ from the samples in the normal
condition so how do we detect this copy
number variation there are ways to
detect this copy number variation using
um
yes using what what is called as snp
microarrays so these are simply um a
targeted sequencing panel that targets
specific snps uh on the whole genome
level and then
cal and then counts the number of times
these snps are um
sequence these smps are red
red in so this is this this method is
still used but
since the next gen sequencing
offers much more
freedom and much more resolution in copy
number variation this has been
superseded by hexane sequencing method
but still nonetheless
this
snp microarray based detection is one of
the better ways to uh is one of the ways
to detect uh and um
quantify copy number variation so in
this specific example
we can see that there is a higher
frequency of s and ps at chromosome 21
and this
indicates and if you quantify this
specific frequency with respect to the
other ones um this indicates that there
is a there is one more copy of
chromosome 21 that is present in this
sample and that is um and hence
and hence
we we can
confirm that there is a trisomy and down
syndrome
uh yeah this is a this is a typical case
of down syndrome due to the trisomy of
chromosome 21 and
using next-gen sequencing method how one
can detect copy number variation is is
by simply locating where these weeds map
onto one can detect copy number
variation like this is homozygous
relation this is a hemis dilation where
it is deleted from only one allele and
this is a copy number gain with respect
to the other um
with respect to the other genes so uh
this is using uh a wholesome mapping uh
mapping on uh mapping of the reads to
the genome and if you uh take a much
more detailed view uh it depends on
where and how these reads are mapped
onto the reference genome we can
actually identify the
identify different copy number variation
effects
using what they call as
[Music]
using what they call as a read bad
methods right so uh
you can have much more uh information on
copy number variation in some associated
lessons that
i will ask uh i will ask um
sonalika spurs to share when you are
receiving the recording of the session
and
basically how would we set up a copy
number variation pipeline uh this we can
set it up as a demo pipeline under copy
number variation
analysis method also so you you start
with pcr clean and
go to mapping and then after mapping you
just start to count the number of copies
that one identifies or that one
associates
the um
associate the genomes are positioned
with uh in this uh with the uh
with with the reference genome so we
will take a look at the output file
quickly now and you have you also also
have from the output files you also have
the um ability to
produce a graph like this which will
give you the copy number variation
levels of
all the different positions or different
positions in the chromosome wise and as
these are color coded and the red means
okay i mean green means gain and red
means
loss
and
you can yeah you can create or you can
make such a profile so that we can
compare the copy number variation of uh
for say for example um
tumor cells with respect to adjacent
hormones and understand
in which parts or which portions of the
chromosome
is involved with higher gain or higher
loss of the significant genes so in
addition to that we can also visualize
this copy number variation in in
in special visualization softwares like
j browser or igb
where in if you do it in igb we have a
specific we have a way to um
assemble related i mean genes that are
related to a specific pathway so this is
a p53 pathway and genes that are related
to p53 pathway if you look closely we
will have the number of copies uh of
these genes present in um present in
this uh present in this specific assam
full output so far um and see the cdk
gene is present only once while the tp53
gene is present uh seven times so it's a
gain in copy number and the mdm2 is also
present four times and then bm4 is also
present four times so um
this information along with uh exemplar
pipelines that we have set up for you to
understand how
cancer biology is is his approach and
how different studies of cancer biology
is approached
are available in our learnomics platform
where we have a lot of cancer-related
projects that will take you through uh
different analysis methods that are
helpful in uh
characterizing and categorizing these
significant variations of genomic and
transcriptomic variation that one
usually observes in the cancerous cells
state so this can be helpful in
understanding what is different in in a
tissue that is that is
proliferating or understanding uh
different subcategories of the cancerous
cells so let me stop here
and go to the
copy number variation pipeline quickly
and show you how you can
set that up
so i wanted to show you some
yeah
so in the
okay
um
in the example pipelines uh yes okay uh
in the example pipeline not this one
so in the example pipelines under copy
number variation segment which most of
these will will come to and this cancer
biology segment soon and
if you click and you will have a demo
copy number variation
pipeline which you can set it up
with this and
following the
highlighter
then we are mapping the sequences back
onto the reference genome and then we
are just beginning or calculating the
number of copies present uh
in this one and then we are clustering
these number of copies and then we are
segmenting it and creating a
end table for different chromosomes
and we are finishing it up
yeah
and we will get the output files i have
downloaded the output files let's take a
look at this specific cnvp value dot ext
output file
if i can open that up
i think i might have to share everything
for you to uh see that okay let's check
let's see that okay
what is the file format of bed file copy
number variations that we visualize in
igv it's a bit file bit file you'll get
uh
put in bit files bam files will give you
alignment and bit files will make you
visualize the copy number variation in a
different format uh
like how many copies of genes that you
have that you have this associated with
the specific sample so let me stop
sharing and start sharing everything so
that you can visualize what what i see
generally
so
so you can see my screen and here i have
actually taken this specific
file and
that is my excel
okay this is what i wanted to show you
and uh
so this actually reports the number of
reports amount of copy number gain for
different sections of
chromosomes for example it has
calculated this chromosome 1 from
0 to this specific position actually
gained the copy number variation of 6
and
hence the status is gain and this this
actually calculates the non-parametric
difference between two types of samples
that i have given that i have used for
this analysis one is tumor one is tumor
uh samples the other one is adjacent
normal
samples
so the copy number uh variation tool
will actually take the bam file and
create a bit file uh the one that does
the segmentation uh that that will
actually generate a bit file so it's in
the pipeline and that is going to
generate you the bit but uh yeah bam
files will give you the alignment
mapping from the alignment mapping you
can obviously calculate the copy number
uh once but you don't have to know that
much but you can generate this from this
file so
so
what is the copy number that i would
expect if there is no uh let's make it a
little bit uh interactive i wanted to
make it interactive but we did not have
time so what is the copy number that i
would uh expect if if for a section that
is that is neither gain or not not lost
does anybody know
please answer your answer in the chat is
it
four five six
i if i can't
it's two no
we will have two copies of all the genes
two copies of everything because we are
deployed organisms so it's two so
anything that is greater than two is
again anything that is lesser than 2 is
a loss let's see if we can find less
than 2 it's yes 1 is a loss see that
this one is a loss and 3 is again so
yeah so that is it and this is a
statistical significance when you
compare the gain with respect to the
normal sample ah this this does um
non-parametric statistical calculations
and kolmogorov you know actually does uh
the distribution analysis and and and
calculates how the distribution of copy
number variation
are these numbers actually are very
um
how their distribution vary with respect
to the two samples so this is what i
wanted to show you uh for today
and that will conclude today's session
and if you have any further questions
please yeah
please
you can admit yourself and ask
uh
can pre-formulated pipelines be used to
analyze and publish data yes you can do
that so how can the publish
you can
directly reference the pipeline in the
using using our link and using our
reference citation so you we have
published this uh
this effort of
of developing this big data bioinfo
platform has been published and you can
use that as a citation or you can simply
use the web server as a citation in your
methodology um
in your
section where often for bioinformatics
analysis you refer the link of the
link or publicly available link for
[Music]
for references so if i have 20 vcf file
for the same disease what analysis can
you do you can actually compile all
these 20 vcf files into one uh
one math file mutation annotation file
that is going to take all these 20
vision files and tabulate it into one
big map file so these 20 vcf files for
different samples you can tabulate it as
one map files and a map file and that
can be subjected to further analysis
like any structured data analysis you
can perform
for example
if you have different
samples you can perform yes mutation
annotation file
so when you download mutation
information from let's say tcga database
that consists of vcs vcf files from
different
different samples and maf protected maf
is a file format that you will get as a
result of compiling all these vcf file
into one
specific file so could you suggest a way
to visualize gta for gfa file format gfo
for gtx can be visualized in the
jbrowser itself um you remember these uh
those okay let me um let me quickly
share my screen
uh not excel
where is my
chrome
so you see my you see this one you see
the you see my screen and
[Music]
for example this information comes from
the gfo file see that so this
information tells which one is exon and
which one is intron and this information
comes from gfo file without this gfo
file this reference
uh file
will not show anything it will just show
me uh
forward stand and reverse run i don't
know where the
exon starts and where the intron starts
and nothing so this is information that
you can take from the gfr file so this
is
any
genomic visualization software will
visualize gff or gta 5 so
that is easier
yes
so i think that will conclude today's
session and i urge all of you to check
uh
yeah i urge all of you to check cut
check that out possible uh check out our
symposium or workshop that we have
scheduled
for for upcoming for the end of this
month
and
i will share the link here with you all
and this symposium is going to have a
lot more uh of cancer biology and there
is a separate
there's a separate uh even to separate
a day dedicated for cancer biology
and yeah session dedicated for cancer
biology and experts from different parts
of the world from companies from
different institutes they are going to
talk about cutting-edge research in
cancer biology and you will also see
student researchers that is done using
the board bioinfor platform which will
actually broaden your mind to all
possible different analysis that can be
performed using uh our using the um
big data bioinformatics platform so this
is this is a this is the way or an
effort
to make this bioinformatics analysis
accessible to many people who are uh not
comfortable in
employing coding or
even if you are comfortable in employing
coding this time spent in
learning different coding aspects of
different algorithms can be spent in uh
devising
or
designing specific hypotheses or
biological questions and then you can
try it out those
analysis methods in in the platform big
data by info platform and then choose
the one that uh
that seems to align with your hypothesis
and then uh go into much detail analysis
using that so we have uh yeah so uh
yeah thank you very much uh
in that aspect today has been a little
bit longer session and uh uh less
interaction
you know why uh for now yeah
hopefully next time it will be more
interactive
thank you very much for everybody and i
yeah i wish you all good day wherever
you are thank you
thank you so much raghav sir for such a
wonderful session and thank you so much
everyone for uh joining the workshop and
if you have any questions please feel
free to reach out to us at support at
the daytime dot bio i'll be sharing the
recording of this workshop with all of
you
and you can go through the recording
once again and follow the pipeline
yourself and then
definitely get back to us with the
questions thank you so much everyone for
joining and looking forward to you once
again thank you